Doug tomorrow should not be successful
he's a middle-aged guy he's not ugly but
he's definitely not like a supermodel
either he has a questionable fashion
sense and he has mediocre production
quality at best I don't really know how
to explain that and I'm not really sure
if Alexis knows how to also yet somehow
in this world of helicopter shots
racetrack footage flexi and Beverly
Hills this quirky middle-aged dude has
literally become hands-down my all-time
favorite car youtuber that I trust more
than anyone else and apparently I'm not
alone and we're gonna be going over all
the quirks and features and then we're
gonna give it a grand score I've always
wanted to say that I also happen to see
a picture of someone sitting in the back
of the take hand and it did look a
little bit cramped I don't know if
someone's 6:3 can try it out and see
what it seems like but but how how does
he get around a million views on every
single video how is this possible let's
find out so those are all the cool
quirks and features of the model 3
listen I really enjoy cars but I
wouldn't consider myself like a car nut
that knows like all the ins and outs
about different types of engines or
suspensions or what-have-you and I'm
willing to bet that you're the same you
don't care about the intricacies of what
straight cut gears are no all you care
about is what the car looks like how
exhilarating is it to drive
how valuable the car is and most
importantly how it would feel to own the
car to maybe use it as a daily driver or
just like a fun weekend car and if you
notice all the things I just mentioned
that the average person cares about none
of them relates to the technical aspects
of a car or in other words the general
public doesn't care about any of that
stuff all they care about is how the car
would make them feel knowing that let's
see what these other popular car
channels on YouTube focus on compared to
Doug beautiful camera work beautiful
editing all the nerdy car specs you
could ever ask for Fortune 918 Spyder in
a six 57.00 still has about twenty point
three psi of boost but when it comes to
the one thing viewers actually care
about an approachable and non
intimidating way to learn how the car
would make them feel they completely
missed the mark
sure lap times around racetracks are
super interesting but only its gear has
that nerd out over that stuff but when
we look at Doug's stuff it's no wonder
that he doesn't really talk about any of
the technical specs of the cars in his
reviews sure he mentions basic stuff
like how powerful the engine is but his
entire videos are all centered around
what the general public cares about how
the cars were make them feel
what it would be like to own the cart to
not only drive it but all of my new
details of getting in and out of the car
the exclusivity of it what your money
would be getting you if you bought the
car heck for a car channel he doesn't
even show the car driving on a road like
at all throughout his entire videos the
closest you get to that is watching him
drive the car from the inside of the car
but why does it still work then it's
because you get to experience what he's
feeling driving the car you can imagine
how you would feel if you were to drive
the car yourself
oh my god that sound it's like a Formula
One car
that is crazy did you hear that and what
is the result of Lists where big-name
channels where movie level production
quality can only capture like a small
audience of gearheads dub captures the
general public and because allah he gets
a ton of more views more support and
overall more success so why is Doug
where he's at he appeals to a bigger
general audience by understanding
exactly what people want here is the
market of car channels in a nutshell you
either have the high production
companies with what seems like an
infinite budget to spend on racetracks
helicopter shots etc or you have the
rich guy that seems to buy a new car
like every single month I'm gonna give
you a tour of my car collection but then
there's Doug and if you've ever watched
a Doug video you know that Doug is kinda
quirky to say the least he's not really
like any of his competitors like at all
I mean come on every video he spends
like 20 minutes going over just the
infotainment system alone he dorks out
over all these little tiny features that
no one else notices he occasionally buys
all these weird obscure cars that no one
knows about and he makes the occasional
dad joke now objectively one would think
the big production qualities with the
fancy cameras and the rich guys flexing
their wealth would win over someone like
Doug but this is actually the main
reason why they're losing to him the
reason why Doug is winning is not just
because he reviews cool cars because
everyone does it's not just because he
appeals and understands what the general
audience wants because a lot of other
people do that as well he's successful
largely because of his unique
personality you don't click on a Doug do
just because it's about a Lamborghini or
a Ferrari after all there's a surplus of
those videos on these cars already know
you click on a Doug Bo because you want
to learn about the cool quirks and
features you want to hear him say this
this this this this this this this you
want to hear his corny jokes and to see
like a six-foot three men pathetically
climb into a very tiny back seat and you
want to learn about the unique
perspective and the small little nuances
and insights that only Doug damira
wouldn't notice or in other words you
watch not just because of the cool car
he's reviewing but also because you
enjoy who he is as a person because
there's no one else quite like Doug so
why is this unlikely man winning where
others focus on things only a small
percentage of the people who are into
cars care about he cuts through all the
fluff and focuses only on the one thing
people do care about how the cars would
make them feel and because of less his
audience pool is much bigger than those
that just focus on like the techie stuff
like deer heads are into but catering to
the right audience isn't enough when
everyone is making the same videos on
the same cars when everyone has kind of
like the same just the same personality
in their videos you need something more
in does case it's his hilarious and
oddly delightful personality to where
you're not just watching for the cars
you're watching because it's Doug and no
one else is quite like Doug and because
of lists where other channels can barely
get any views of them getting sporadic
and inconsistent views at best this just
goes to show how far understanding your
customers understanding your audience in
this case and having a unique
perspective can take you
[Music]
so thank you so much for watching and
being part of Lee watch the end Club you
guys and if you are new to this channel
I do videos like this worse like video
essays or the entrepreneur niche so if
you enjoy the style of content please
consider subscribing attorney on a
notification Belser youtube notifies you
whenever I release a new video every
single week that is literally the best
way to support this channel and also let
me know who or what you want me to do a
video on next in the comments down below
you can follow me on instagram at jake
trend io I think that's enough shameless
plugs for now so thank you so much for
watching you been awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]